[Musica]
ciao a tutti i veneti solide mani di non
avere che ozzy nuova challenge grande
grandissima richiesta la peggiore della
estrema basso che fa persone alla volta
che mie preferite
quindi abbiamo deciso di farlo nata con
la nota questa volta è un po diversa
però in pratica la ruota desidera il
colore delle decorazioni e noi dovremo
prendere una decorazione a nostra scelta
di quel colore di bello quindi possiamo
comunque scegliere cosa però deve essere
quel colore che si capita in più c'è
anche lo scambio e c'è anche sceglie
l'altro sicuramente m3 poterle belle ma
lei se volete vedere altre challenge il
colle ruota cosiddetti sicure che altre
salento fare con la ruota 50 stessi
ricordi
prendete i pop corn e iniziò subito
carta forbice carta fabbricato
presenti a piano piano
[Musica]
quindi chi è dio che queste cose bene se
no ti ripeto dove sono vabbè
cioè mi chiusi dai capi sono le piccole
come tale non mettete lasciate un
commento alla scritta unità perfida vita
è la cosa che ad esibirsi non è fisico e
quindi preso smettila piccolo
[Musica]
ne esce un po che dimenticati di dire
che io oggi sono team verde guardate
bene per due gruppi però adesso rivedere
beta per vedere se mi aiuta magari
seduti verde non mi capite il verde no
vedremo tocca a me vecchio giro piano
[Musica]
che opportuno e di chi girando piano tra
tutte queste cose vista chi scelgo tra i
pigmenti se un bel colore così su
giacche rosse in lucina l'imbarco lo
giudico per quest'altro ballo il
pigmento perlato mio è attenta che un
testo poi dopo se ti viene qualche altro
colore questi diventa marrona io devo
avvisato io ti ho avvisato il resto del
bacino perché dopo lo rischieremo
preferita
[Musica]
ciao ciao
che fortuna per scegliere qualsiasi cosa
però deve essere la roja è in rotta con
gli spot non è quello che ci vuole
[Musica]
ma bastava per uscire se gli era entrato
il risultato integrato e si torna anche
a me che bello chiese si sa rendere le
palline perché non prendi questa rosa
no non ne voglio farli ne aveva venti
glitter dopo vi facciamo vedere come di
visti ai bellissimi ma anche se questi
diritti non mi piace anche a me però
bello
[Musica]
seppellito individuo qualsiasi cosa lì
quindi scelgo cosa non ottimali comporti
incremento troppo pericoloso si è che
sono le showgirl carino bellissimi
schiavo lo vediamo questo piccolo evento
se prendo un po dai rosa celeste rosa
sta benissimo in questa schifezza più di
mezzo secondo
secondo te il colore violetto giusta
bene ma tutti questi glitter rosaneri
che in asso ben attimo di tempo a picchi
che fantastica e magica la stima di pupo
ping cresce un sacco vediamo come è
diventato apposto adesso insidia santi
adesso sembra parma bello è bellissimo
sarà super proposto vediamo invece il
tuo adesso mischiato che era a terra
come te l'ho fatto bene tutti questi
anni
vediamo allora secondo me ci sta molto
bene
che fortunato è già diventando un gala
che corre con una gru cina già
nuovamente che sta richiamando allora
vediamo di mettere del colorante
colorante rosso colore letto grigio e
grigio via verso greta e credo quindi
torna a dream è un po di coraggio
aumentarlo primo modo io pure fortunato
gioco e matteo di rosso in effetti bo
strano perché questo slimer rosa chiaro
se metto il rosso non so di che colore
potrebbe venire schermito il colorante
così lo faccia proprio na dove messo
rosa come diventa con il rosa chiaro
terremoto
[Musica]
grazie al progetto che piaceva io vedo
lo riprendo il mio fido detto il rigetto
grazie al contrario al contrario vuol
dire che io mi devo girare ma quindi che
cosa puoi prendere tutto okay combinando
ma il primo avevo è stata allora gli
ingredienti sono da qui sono tutti qua
anche quindi ero anche il piccolo è
questo va bene
guardo ancora più vicino non l'ho preso
così
non perde comunque avete rotto e di già
messo in rosa 4 grammi cose dati a rosa
e vita visto che bravo risultato
ok vediamo come sia rosso che hanno
messo il mio ultimo è ritornato indietro
vediamo poi c'è un profumo buonissimo
questo smalti ho letto quindi sportivi
20 in viola ancora più scuro si pentirà
di averlo scambiato sacco di colore
magari esce bel scuro scusa al tronista
ma che bello il colore stupendo fino
alla quale vi piazza alterne con coloro
conoscitiva molto belle via grazie
perché tutto questo colore quelli cioè
gara che l'effetto anche io quando ero
al contrario è
[Musica]
scegli tu
bene poi metto un po di colorante no
metto un po di kit ma mi ha detto
corrosa che bper stanno bene chiedere
quale di queste pagine progetto dai
vestiti glitter dei marchi altissimi
[Musica]
guarino di cosa che prendo sociali
lorenzo più bello infatti lorenzo viola
bellissimo adesso mi devo prendere
questo policli per legge tranne bike o
meno blu ma come se blu e viola
mettiamo le palline questa volta quindi
non vuoi fare france and roll e rametti
è quindi io praticamente negli ultimi
due turni che ho scelto due blue note
che con cui il tuo colore preferito di
multa betty blue da set
vediamo due milioni di in gruppo no
adesso aggiungiamo le altre
lo ha scritto che chiudiamo le palline
prima che io la butto facciata faccio
casino mischiamo peso di vita in arte
moda e già ci sono
questo è semi granci oppure magari dopo
aggiungo un altro po di palline colorate
non lo so mancano ancora tantissimi
ingredienti potremo scegliere tantissime
io invece bruxelles tutto che non
c'entravano o meno volta che bello che
sto diventando la guarda sembra merial e
programmi quello molto bello no ci
stanno malissimo e se si guarda che
peggio almeno potevi spegnerli rosa
viola così sembrava la cosa sul rosa una
fragola sembrava invece che non
c'entrano niente parola palette è
diventato blu praticano la terra perché
manca poco alla fine a chi toccare
invece non è ancora capitato tra l'altro
quindi speriamo non capiti proprio
quello che è chiamato web occhi chiusi
ok puoi iniziare possono service chiari
gli occhi
si va da sé ma ho paura che cosa hai mai
perso
l'avete già presa festa come mi piace
perché stavamo scrivi distesi io l'ho
messo tutti in piedi ma stavano lo
stesso posizioni ma ha il potere di
trasformare qualsiasi sisley suoi
chiesto a questo si deve aggiungere alla
fine perché file potters lai un po e
quindi non la posso aggiungere adesso
però se capita scambio viene scambiato
si sa lo sa anche questo perché fa già
parte dello slam e quindi stai molto
attento perché intendo trasformerà un
errore
[Musica]
rai o anche tu sia nella ruota ha detto
mi aspetta
[Applauso]
di fatto si va in cerca del verde la
cosa
poi per terra tutto questo aggiungiamo
che uno degli abili dai velisti spostato
che gli occhi ai prezzo del joy
neroverdi ott
sembravano sembrarono zavoli e verso
l'alto pulire membri malati sfida che
sono ancora io perché questo è l'ultimo
turno spero che vi capiti scout così la
giacchetta va a vitale media e sebbene
scellerato patto mettiamo
[Musica]
non ho raggiunto previste sono carini
tae ho scelto io allora ora dobbiamo
attivare i nostri slimer qui non vedo
come si sono stupiti vitale come
cacchetta colorati il laccio scritto
quindi sui migranti
[Risate]
3 ecco wildlife allora che era poi di
evitare che era poi mio che era pure
digital è comunque riuscito un
bellissimo viola come stupendo
poi ci sono le palline poi la
consistenza è fighissimo allo stesso non
è molto famoso che un pò più rigido però
dovrà franci del da tempo sentiamo i
suoni
[Musica]
quindi questo è kim hughes line ma mi
piace un sacco estendibile un po
coraggiosa e fa un bel booking e ora
siamo curiosissimi di vedere quello di
evitare finiano guarda quant'è bello il
team online invece
[Musica]
il sito è un mega contratto è andato
firma di papà ping è bellissimo perché
colore colore rosa inseguimenti con
ritardo le palline blu le fishbowl blu
volevo dire che non sono caduto perché
l'ottimo non bellissimo keber umori e
stupendo davvero bellissimo fitti i
bikers life è uscito benissimo vena un
momento ma tu devi aggiungere qualcosa
che devo aggiungere la cassetta ma dai
marroncino bruttissimi ora apriamo lo
prende vediamo affettivo perché
consistenza fantastica aprono benissimo
con questa rosa
bevendo all'atp di per sé va a farlo
parte come è nata per buono inizia tutto
bene e sui temi e propria stanza senza
colpa mia
[Musica]
avevo capito che brutto tratta di molto
meno del settore di non mi rompere uno
slide dei giochi del padroncino però sei
fortunato perché non è diventato troppo
scuro chiarimento tra la vasta stato
cominciato a cadere pure le palline
verte numero morbido e sophie toso
rispetto a prima però la data sembra
quasi pesca un color pesca
ce la farà se lo immaginate bene conosco
quindi
in una cassetta conosco loro zyl hanno
rovinato una bellissima
allora chi vince clarke ha aiutate per
me votate per me perché era un
bellissimo mi devo aggiungere questa
vecchietti questo color kaki e allora
votate qualche vince servizio evitare
aste b line thin light e volete
attrezzamenti con la ruota e ora vi
lasciamo 4 castellini su wii cliccare
per vedere i nuovi video video
divertenti
live clicca qui